when Disney wrestled Star Wars from the
cold clutches of George Lucas for pretty
much the bargain of the century they
understandably wanted to protect their
newfound investment and they did that by
announcing new movies to get everyone
excited before quietly declaring all of
the existing Star Wars Expanded Universe
non-canon in the words of George Lucas
crush you like a bug yes no need to go
GG so a bunch of comics video games and
books got slapped with the label Star
Wars legends and quietly taken out
behind the shed I'm sure while Disney
worked on bringing us a new stories like
rogue one and the han solo movie shawhan
and the Death Star are iconic pieces of
Lucas law but we think there are other
tales in the Star Wars universe that are
dying to be told it's why I've spin-offs
we'd like to see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there will be a substantial reward for
the one who finds the Millennium calton
you are free to use any methods
necessary but I want them Allah no
disintegrations many people believe the
love of Boba Fett isn't really deserved
considering he isn't in the original
trilogy for that long and he doesn't do
much more than look cool and get Ian
Albert in the expanded universe more
specifically the Bounty Hunter Wars
trilogy of books Boba's descent into the
Sarlacc pit was in the end of the
mandalorian bounty hunter he actually
kills the Beast and makes an escape and
although badly wounded he isn't saved
until bounty hunter dengar finds him in
the wreckage much of the story is set
during bobas flashbacks he has won his
healing which means there would be tons
to explore in a spin-off movie over the
course of three books he fights droid
assassins visits the bounty hunter guild
and even tracks down the killer of loops
aunt and uncle for now it's unsure
whether or not he's alive i'm dead on
one hand those books on canon lemoore
but on the other we do see him escape
the Sarlacc pit in the battlefront
trailer but one thing's for sure Star
Wars needs more Mandalorian badasses I
[Music]
spent that Mon Hanja club watch that
investment back too I never made a deal
with kanjiklub tell that to kanjiklub
I absolutely love the force awakens but
if there's one thing in there that
really annoys me it's how little the
kanji club were featured in it and that
needs to change in the movie the most
prominent among them were rukan the--and
castle each who are played by eko voice
and yang yang Liu Jian you might know
these two as the stars of the raid
redemption and the rate to these guys
are basically martial arts gods I mean
just pick any random moment from either
of those two films and chances are it
will be a jaw-dropping showcase of their
abilities here let's try it hit him
again see what I mean and in the force
awakens they just strike a chord pose
for a few seconds and then I never seen
again if you ask me that is just a
criminal way to treat those two actors
and a waste of some cool world building
opportunities my solution anything I'll
take it I just really want to see Star
Wars lean into the Kung Fu side of the
universe
as one of the biggest questions raised
by the force awakens other than through
a ruse burns was just who are these
stylish guys those stylish chaps would
be the Knights of Ren a dark side
organization under the control of
Supreme Leader Snoke while they were on
the side of the baddies the Knights of
Ren word part of the formal hierarchy of
the first order but kind of had military
freedom which is why the members of the
first order tolerate kylo Ren's [ __ ]
Fitz
so how did this stylish group of
specters get pounded who are the men I'm
meeting women behind the masks in the
immortal words of the who I don't know
why you looking at me I don't have the
answers I know who might force awakens
director JJ Abrams when asked which
story he'd like to see told in an
anthology movie Abrams revealed I guess
the one thing I would say is that
there's a Knights of Ren story that I
think would be pretty cool to tell well
don't hold out on us Jay brooms what
does it mean do you already have a story
in mind or not how did the polar bear
get on the island i am not going through
this again
nice yard Republic is still probably one
of my favorite bio air titles being able
to create a Jedi my own image boy that
twist circuit there's a lot of scope for
a strong cast full of characters each
struggling with our own role in the
universe being pulled by both the light
side and the dark side of the force all
while maintaining a dark secret from the
audience the game story be great to see
on the big screen but it's the universe
as a whole I am most interested in
Knights the old republic is set about
4,000 years before the rise the Galactic
Empire which means you'd get to see a
galaxy much older than one we explore
the movies that means there are factions
and planets and races that don't exist
anywhere else in the Star Wars universe
and a movie going that far back in the
time I would have way more creative
freedom than any movies around the
current movies would no ma'am mrs. stay
mr. coach Adam pinks mrs. your humble
servant the Star Wars prequel trilogy is
a hot-button topic some people love them
redlettermedia hates them or if we can
all agree on one thing and so it gave us
the greatest character that universe has
ever seen Jar Jar Binks I mean just look
at how much Lucy loves him loofa I'm
judge a Buddhist Fantana disgusting of
course I am kidding he's awful and I
wished he would get forced choke to
death every second he was on the screen
how would but you know what I'd still
like to see him get his own spin-off
movie under one strict condition it's an
adaptation of the amazing jaja is a Sith
Lord theory if you're not familiar with
the theory allow me to give you the
cliff notes version George I exhibit
some abilities that only a Sith would be
capable of including a twisting
somersault in the air Jojo is shown to
be using maneuvers that are very similar
to the drunken fist fighting style which
to the untrained eye looks like
stumbling around and tripping over like
a buffoon but is actually a calculated
and expertly executed series of
movements that catch the enemy off God
next up we have evidence that he's also
capable of using Jedi mind tricks in the
scenes way looks like he's haphazardly
convincing people into giving him what
he wants he's actually using subtle hand
move
the best example of this is when he's
speaking to the Galactic Senate and
convinces everyone to give emergency
powers to Palpatine emergency powers to
the Supreme Chancellor if you go back
and watch the prequel trilogy you may
notice that in the majority of Palpatine
scenes jaja is at his side and this has
led to the idea that Jar Jar may
actually be the master and Palpatine is
his apprentice I'm sure you'll agree
that this is a one hundred percent
watertight infallible theory and we all
can't wait to see a movie based on the
floppy eared devil so there's five star
wars spin-offs that we'd like to see but
what about you let us know in the
comments box below for more videos like
this one make sure to LIKE and subscribe
to gamespot universe and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]